e aí
e eu peço licença antes de iniciar aos
nossos ancestrais
e aos mais velhos e os mais novos 1
hoje eu vim aqui falar algumas coisas
para vocês mas antes de falar eu queria
fazer um convite eu queria que vocês
largasse um pouquinho as coisas que
vocês têm na mão os braços
é apenas descruzar um pouquinho sabe
relaxar um pouquinho nessa cadeira
e aí
e pronto respirar fundo e fechar os
olhos
g1
e tem gente com olho aberto e fechado
e eu quero convidar vocês a resgatar um
pouco a trajetória de vocês mas dessa
vez olhando de fora é
o e olhando numa outra perspectiva
eu disse infância todos nós ouvimos
muitas coisas
e muitas coisas sobre as pessoas como
são e como agem o que fazem e dessa vez
eu queria que vocês lembrassem
olá tudo que você já ouviram sobre o que
é ser negro
e os negros são
e aí
g1
e os negros fazem
eu tinha que ser coisa de negro e
e aí
e eu quero que vocês percebam como vocês
se sentem com todas as brincadeiras as
falas tudo que vocês ouviram nessa
trajetória
o quê agora vocês imaginem que na frente
de vocês tem uma criança negra
e ouvindo tudo isso
e pode abrir
e quem daqui
se lembrou de coisas negativas pode
levantar a mão por favor olha ao redor
pode manter a mão levantada bem alto por
favor
o ok alguém aqui só lembrou de coisas
positivas que bom eu acho que só teve
uma pessoa mas significa que a gente
está no caminho legal pelo menos
é é todos nós sabemos e por mais que a
gente não tenha todo conteúdo teórico ou
esteja por dentro de toda a discussão
todos nós sabemos o que é racismo
o e aprendemos desde cedo que que é seja
na brincadeira no vizinho naquela frase
acreditado popular sabe todos nós
sabemos e e todos nós sabemos também que
o racismo ele ele deixa todos nós
desconfortáveis
e ele mexe com emoções negativas em
todos nós
ah e por mais que eu quisesse vir aqui
falar de outra coisa voltar da questão
social no brasil eu não tenho como falar
de social sem falar sobre racial o nosso
país foi construído em cima de racismo
olá boa parte de todas as construções
que a gente tem hoje foram a partir a
partir da escravidão de colocar um povo
acima de outro
e e eu comecei a sua dinâmica só para
que a gente saiba de onde a gente tá
partindo eu gosto muito da definição do
munanga que traz que racismo é quando eu
ligo o meu corpo físico ao intelecto a
uma cultura ou a uma moral que é
superior ou inferior a de outro corpo
físico de uma outra raça raça é um
conceito político e social de dominação
de um povo sobre o outro e eu gostaria
que você segurar essa definição porque
eu tô eu tô aqui muito além de falar de
racismo eu quero contar para vocês uma
história
e em 2014 eu tive a oportunidade de
conhecer uma comunidade aqui de
florianópolis e essa comunidade fica
localizado ali é próxima mauro ramos
próximo ao esqui e é uma comunidade
remanescente de quilombo e segunda
comunidade com maior contingente de
população negra daqui então ela tem
muita gente negra lá e isso mexeu muito
comigo quando eu tive contato com essa
comunidade por me ver nas pessoas enfim
identificar mas quando eu me conhecia
essa comunidade eu conheci primeiramente
através das crianças
e eu tava recém-formada em psicologia e
eu sempre falava nunca nunca nunca quero
trabalhar com criança porque se eu tô
com uma criança eu vi o criança junto e
não vai dar certo enfim eu sei que tem
um negócio que ela você traz um
pouquinho e começou a tentar da minha
vida aquela coisa de criança e ela
descobriram que eu fazia dança que ia
fazer teatro e nós queremos dançar funk
comigo elas queriam mostrar apresentação
que elas fizeram coisas do tipo assim e
foi muito legal sabe foi muito legal
porque a gente começou a brincar e no
meio das suas brincadeiras eu senti que
a gente se aproxima muito e quem tem
contato mais próximo com criança sabe o
quanto elas se soltam mesmo assim quando
elas sentem julgados né então eles
começaram a falar e desabafar o que elas
estavam vivendo assim e dentro desabafos
que elas trouxeram teve um que mexeu
muito comigo já era algumas crianças m
os dentes que se elas pudessem escolher
elas seriam loiras de olhos azuis aquilo
mexeu muito comigo não só pelas coisas
da mídia sabe por saber que a gente só
tem princesa que assim assim sarro não
por questões teóricas sabe mas porque eu
já estive naquele lugar só que eu estive
naquele lugar sozinha sabe e eu nunca
tive coragem de verbalizar isso mas eu
eu estive naquele lugar justo nos
momentos em que eu passava por alguma
dificuldade que eu pensava assim se eu
fosse exatamente igual loira de olhos
azuis isso aqui seria diferente
e essa situação não seria assim eu teria
uma oportunidade diferente
e eu não sei vocês mas eu quando eu vejo
uma situação dessas eu não consigo ficar
indiferente sabe é não é porque eu tava
meio revoltado com a psicologia pensando
o quê que é psicologia poderia fazer por
comunidades em que a psicologia nunca
trabalho exatamente com esse público
aquela coisa toda mas eu pensei assim
quer saber é uma questão pessoal aqui
sabe eu preciso fazer alguma coisa e na
época que a gente fez pegamos um
instrumentos e chamamos as crianças e
começamos a trabalhar alguns cantos
afirmativos a contar as histórias a
partir de música a partir de dança
partir de teatro quero que elas queriam
não era então eu pensei olha falar de
racismo não vai mudar muita coisa como
todos nós sabemos fica só falando não
muda a gente precisa mostrar uma outra
forma
oi e aí tá contar para vocês como foi
isso eu queria propor uma interação
nossa pode ser ai credo
bom obrigada valeu então seguinte eu vou
pedir para vocês levantarem e isso tô
aqui em pé sem muleta conto com vocês e
eu vou pedir para que vocês acompanhem
na palma pode ser eu vou chamar duas
meninas aqui comigo para me ajudarem vem
cá tainá e maria e a gente vai cantar o
seguinte a
e fala para elas maravilhosas aí auê auê
auê olha lá olha lá auê auê auê lelelê
lelelê lelelê ooo tem gente que não tá
batendo palma lelelê lelelê ooo a
capoeira é da nossa flor é da nossa cor
é
e aí
e ao e lê lê lê lê lê
[Aplausos]
e a maria é da nossa cor a tainá é da
nossa cor a matze é da nossa cor o teu
deck é da nossa cor angela davis é da
nossa cor manda lá lá
e aí
bom obrigada valeu eu acho que esse povo
podia dançar mas ok palminha já tá
valendo agradeço muito a interação uma
palmas para elas e para nossa percussão
obrigada e a gente começou a fazer isso
é esse canta um canto da capoeira que a
gente começou a colocar as crianças em
roda e cada um - centro e a gente
lembrava que elas eram na nossa cor
assim como angela davis a da nossa cor
assim como mandar ela da nossa cor assim
como um zumbi da nossa cor assim como
várias construções que a gente tem no
brasil hoje são na nossa cor e muitas
vezes a gente deixa de falar a gente
deixa de considerar na hora de falar
história a gente deixa de colocar os
pontos que a cultura negra aquilombô
brasil porque o uso dizer que a cultura
negra a cultura popular brasileira
o quilombo de cultura negra muito do que
a gente vive hoje diz de cultura negra
só que às vezes a gente não tem essa
percepção por conta do racismo e
e aí surgiu é da nossa cor esse grupo
que tem me acompanhado e tem me ensinado
coisas maravilhosas principalmente o
poder de transformação que a cultura
pode ter e quando eu falo cultura eu não
tô falando só de dança percussão canto
eu tô falando de valores lá pro
civilizatórios como oralidade o falar
com o corpo inteiro para além de
discurso para além de verbal para além
de falei soltas é falar a nossa verdade
a corporeidade esse corpo que todos nós
temos que é marcado de história história
dos que vieram antes de nós de todos que
estão com a gente tudo que a gente vive
cicatrizes dores conquistas também
a circularidade a nossa capacidade de
estar juntos esse olhar no mesmo nível
porque nós podemos fazer isso mas quando
ele está em círculo a gente se sente
mais à vontade para fazer isso para
olhar nos olhos
a ludicidade a nossa capacidade de rir
diante de problemas de achar soluções e
meio brincadeiras e isso a população
negra fez muito né diante tudo isso
construir muita coisa brincando é um
dono musicalidade que é um dom que nós
temos né foi meio desafinado aqui foi
mas tentamos ir e foi gostoso quando a
atividade a nossa compreensão de que eu
e eu e nós estamos muito conectados não
existe ação isolada tudo que eu faço
interfere diretamente e indiretamente em
cada um de vocês eu sou responsável
pelas minhas ações e sou responsável por
vocês também que vão ter um impacto dela
a memória
a memória é lembrar da nossa história e
não esquecer dela porque ela que faz a
gente olhar para o futuro
a ancestralidade é saber que eu estou
aqui e representes todos que vieram
antes de mim todos que estão aqui comigo
e todos que ainda estão por vir é minha
responsabilidade social de estar aqui
agora com os trem da história
o axé a energia vital que faz a gente
acordar todos os dias com motivação para
fazer as coisas acontecerem todos nós
temos cosmovisão algumas pessoas chamam
de religiosidade eu gosto de cosmovisão
porque dentro da cosmovisão africana
todos e tudo que tem o nosso redor esse
chão essas cadeiras tudo essa grava tudo
é natureza se a natureza sagrada e eu
faço parte da natureza eu sou sagrada
então é um cuidado com tudo que tem o
nosso redor cada coisinha cada pequeno
detalhe é sagrado e pode gerar tanta
coisa a gente conseguiu fazer tanta
coisa com um mínimo
e nós conseguimos
bom e o que tudo isso tem a ver com
equidade racial vocês lembram quando eu
falei da definição de munanga desligar
esse corpo a uma moral a uma cultura ao
intelecto inferior eu tô aqui para
mostrar para vocês que este corpo ele
pode estar ligado a algo muito maior que
é uma cosmovisão que é uma valorizar
para civilizatórios que que ajudaram a
construir o brasil que ajudaram e
contribuíram e muitas outras coisas e
hoje tudo que a gente tem construído em
tecnologia partir daí tudo que a gente
tem construído em negócios nessas novas
gerações de negócios aprendi com essa
cultura a gente volta para origem é o
meu desafio para vocês é que a gente
possa olhar para além do problema e
buscar a solução aonde a gente considera
a beirada porque dentro do problema é
muito difícil a gente achar solução
agora quando a gente olha
em todas as vezes ele tem a solução para
as margens às vezes ali pode ser o
centro e eu convido a cada um de vocês a
pensar como cada um dentro do que tem
pode construir dia após dia uma
transformação dentro da equidade racial
e social e é isso obrigada
[Aplausos]